hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play gray all right my name is
markiplier and we just got some bullets
finally by me we didn't just get
supposed I don't know when we got
bullets been a while since I played like
a whole day donk ulis anyway so we got a
gun though
and there's creepy drawings and it's
about it hmm
okay so we're moving forward creepy
hospital where nothing good can happen
most positive big empty room ah the exam
room no cell phone using in I thought we
were in swedenland was everything in
English hmm or the Netherlands is I
think someone pointed out ooh
this looks creepy yeah halfway expecting
something to happen if I stepped in the
middle of that button no all right
it's locked now Cantor Burke ah [ __ ] you
you son of a [ __ ] I swear that dushman
ah man you doesn't even actually hurt
you just dared I screw with you guys
monkey [ __ ] looking looking looking lose
you lose nope ah nope up we go up with
your father
good gun got ya now I'm thinking about I
didn't need to waste all my ammo on you
let's try that again the information I
found though illuminating was unexpected
okay whatever I'm ready for you Oh step
right in aha got your know hey effective
come on guys
help Oh boom did pund
yeah so that's actually so positive oh
it's a double Peter Pan floaty Fest get
your lumps Wow oh that hurt oh you did
your dick dick dick dick where is that I
know though the medicine cabinet so
frigging hospitals we gotta be medicine
cabinet everywhere there it is cries
still free none of them that's it yeah
Frick and frack and that's what I get
for trying to it's not a crowbar ism
pipe God never mind ma fer I know I have
a med kit I could use a moment but I
don't want to
this sucks appease bullets do nothing in
comparison to everything else
Piper it's more than bullets I mean I'm
a strong but I don't make that much
sense it's locked
ah looks like everything in here looks
baloney cuz all my bullets and all my
health I guess it's time to use my med
kit coz I'm an idiot me I'll have
problem playing games I use my phone as
my timer so that's why it's right there
I'm getting flashbacks from cry fear
right now well if you don't know I'm
talking about and cry fear they're
working from those all quarantine off
with police tape and it had chains on
man
I don't creepy creepy - it's okay is it
nothing good here
oh well that's her neck limit but for
the best I didn't want to have to mess
with ya boozy Anna girl girl love it
services I don't even know this
it's a machine pistol Oh crapola where
the heck am I gonna get a code I didn't
even see a code I see
Hospital archive all these doors is
logged so I have to go back down I came
all the way up here for another limbs
why can't I go anywhere directly I have
to find another way yes I have to find
another way dot this is very very hunky
everything's out to get me
actually this country everybody's out to
get Rory bender
where is the archive the archive in here
no here no no box of die transmission
yes cannot smash those so where is these
hi hi hey you show me were you laughing
at me Oh were you laughing at me Moo's
oh yeah
screwing around in your little trolley
yes I don't have time for your bull I've
got a world to save herself in I'm gonna
go crazy
drill more holes in little unsuspecting
children totally same manner and not
crazy at all
I'm hoping that didn't actually happen
I'm really hoping that didn't really
happen cause otherwise cuz I remember
the end of afraid of monsters
gotcha Katya homicidal mania in one of
the endings yeah I won't spoil it all
but if you go back and watch my
playthrough of afraid of monsters which
is located right up there somewhere
it's over there
knowing more there no it's over there I
don't know
I'll put it things go party better here
I've already been around here how can I
get lost again how can I be now so
ding-dong-dang Ernie must have been in
here because I didn't see maybe there's
like numbers on the walls maybe there's
some clue that I'm you seem like they
might be breakable what is you what is
you ter gotta be a purpose for this room
or not at all ah okay
now they're tag people I'm so popular
it's for Duncan's he can't stop talking
to me alright well looks like I'm lost
again I don't have a co special
chemicals I don't even know I wouldn't
even go in specially I'm out of here I'm
out of this friggin hot bill i'm gone
home
ah screw you guys I'm going home the
same yeah there's got to be like the
archives on the archives are got to be
somewhere that's obviously not special
chemicals that's for damn sure
nothing overhears assembly room and
there was exam room lots of rooms come
on Rudy give it up moving let's get out
here I'm out of here
Roo you guys I'm going home ah no no I'm
strapped I'm not strapped entrapped so
now now I am forced forced to try to
meticulously make my way through this
entire zone to try to figure out what
the heck e heck I'm doing with my life
somehow I need to explain my family then
I play video games for a living
I'm such a sad-sack I screamed like a
little girl for a living that that.oh
documents is this rude oh wait a minute
document ongoing I meant fight for ever
planet whoa Oh Scooby's IV call me I
don't know a suzannecross General
Hospital I went in here I was in here
there were nothing in here for me there
like a note on the floor that I might
have missed somewhere why does that big
of an idiot answer is probably answer is
a resounding it's quite possible hmm
man I'm just gonna hang around till
another one of those little guys
scooting around and his trolley comes
after me it's interesting in the way
these guys die I mean how that's kind of
funny but this guy seemed like he died
in actual normal clothes I don't know if
what normal closest to that meticulously
looking again I'll probably in the bath
I didn't even really look in here ah ah
see right there ah right there actually
that's very obscure that is actually
very obscure four nine eight two three
four nine eight two three four nine
eight two three four nine eight two
three four nine eight two three that
actually is kind of scary I wouldn't
have pegged me to be able to get that
four nine eight two three four nine
eight two three four nine eight two
three four 93 I got it I'm gonna get it
I'm gonna get it cuz I'm a genius
yeah come on you guys got it for naught
hey dude three bit speeding yeah you
guys gotta admit that that was not very
obvious hahaha god damn scissor head
[ __ ] you
cara cara was not I should i I should
have realized I were doing something
right I was hopping around so much with
nothing six five two oh six
hmm enter six five two oh six okay six
five two oh six or something else
special chemical in here that I could
use in this baby these bullets are the
best special chemicals around ah here we
go oh thank you six five two oh six six
five two O's ah God I'm popular tonight
I swear these are all different people
that have been acting exciting to Isis
great week
yeah I'm huge kind of oh this is just
here ah no I guess I'll go run oh you're
cute
none of us here we go all right
how's it need to here's the only reason
to go in there was for the health things
six-five 206 say it with me guys six
five two oh six six five two oh six six
six five two six then dump dead breath
dick come on I can't break any of these
gonna be joking
that's ball hockey ball Oh huh what did
that was that let's talk 206 I don't
like this area oh hi
I knew it I knew it I brought did your
bone but god yeah
I hate don't think I hate those things
ah got ya and I'm bad shot
ordinarily I'm a good shot but I'm not
good with gaming ah who's there all you
oh I should kill you this time
ah not another one oh well look get out
of here man
back to the hoozy golly I swear man
everything I don't like this place at
all that one broke Oh every single box
prove it one one fells whoo oh I don't
like time for smash succeeding
battery is for no reason I'm thinking on
hard it must be something okay all right
anyway
Tammy ah they all far with you basement
during construction oh god damn screw
you buddy
Oh what does it deal with that Oh anyway
that's all the time I got for this
episode God can we get startled by his
own voice so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always see you bye
bye